let's get to this day in history this
day in history this is a fitting this
day in history as they frequently are
all nature is but art unknown to thee on
this day in history
in 1606 Guy Fawkes the chief conspirator
and the plot to blow up the British
Parliament building jumped to his death
on the way up to be executed you all
know the Guy Fawkes mask it's worn by
pseudo rebellious idiots who occupy wall
street and wear gynecological headwear
while they shriek profanities in protest
of nothing in particular you've seen
these things it's come to serve as a
universal symbol of resistance of
protest but ask any of the people
wearing the masks and I would bet you my
Shapiro election cheque that they have
no idea who Guy Fawkes is or what he
stood for so I rather like this story as
the resident papist
at the Daily wire I look forward to
harshing all the lefties Melos the night
before the general parliamentary session
in 1605 on November 4th justice of the
peace
Sir Thomas Givet discovered Guy Fawkes
in the cellar of the parliament building
with 4,000 pounds of gunpowder Fox
belonged to a group of disillusioned
English Catholics organized by Robert
Catesby who sought to blow up
figuratively and literally
England's Protestant government all the
way up to King James the first who was
set to attend Parliament that day on
November 5th now James notoriously
persecuted both aspects of my ancestry
English Puritans and Catholics there are
a few subjects on which Catholics and
Mayflower passengers agree James the
first is one of them in the ensuing
months after Fox's capture English
authorities rounded up and killed all of
the conspirators in the Gunpowder Plot
in addition to arresting torturing and
killing dozens of English Catholics who
had absolutely nothing to do with it Guy
Fawkes was sentenced to be hanged drawn
and quartered by January 31st but as he
climbed the ladder rather than give the
Anglicans that pleasure he jumped from
the ladder and broke his own neck a Guy
Fawkes Day is celebrated throughout
Great Britain on the 5th of November
with fireworks bonfires the burning in
effigy of Guy Fawkes celebrating the day
that Protestant England survived one
wonder is how different
English history and world history would
have progressed had the plot prevailed
English Henry the eighth rather famously
broke Britain away from her ancestral
Catholic faith
despite in 1521 having written a book so
critical of Martin Luther that Pope Leo
the tenth gave him the title defender of
the faith an ironic title because in
1535 frustrated that the Pope kept
stymieing Henry's desires to divorce and
murder his wives and Ari declared
himself supreme head of the Church of
England for which he was excommunicated
by Pope Paul the 3rd in 1570 pope saint
pius v excommunicated Henry's younger
daughter Elizabeth the first and
declared her officially deposed for her
persecution of Catholics in England and
we are not just talking about your
everyday run-of-the-mill persecution of
Catholics what we're seeing throughout
the world for so long
we're talking about behead your own
sister Mary Queen of Scots for being
Catholic kind of persecution of
Catholics
is this sort of persecution that makes
many literary scholars think Shakespeare
was a secret Catholic anyway after
Elizabeth's death in 1603 James the
sixth of Scotland succeeded her and
became James the first of England anyway
they changed their names a lot through
their reigning names so he became James
the first James was a Protestant but
unlike Elizabeth he had never been a
Catholic there was no time at which he
was a Catholic James is the first cradle
Protestant monarch of England and it's
easy for us now especially watching the
crown or whatever movies are coming out
it's easy for us to think of England as
a Protestant country but you shouldn't
forget Catholicism reigned in England
for well over a thousand years there
have been much longer than any
Protestant reign múltiples is long there
had been Celtic Christianity largely in
accordance with Rome from the 1st
century AD and st. Agustin of Canterbury
brought the first authoritative papal
mission establishing a direct link
between the Kingdom of Kent and the sea
of Rome in 597 had the Gunpowder Plot
worked dislodge from England the merely
two generations old Protestantism
affected by two murderers one who killed
his wives and the other who killed her
sister
would England have reverted to her
ancestral Catholic faith would the King
James version of the Bible considered by
many
the greatest work of the English
language would that exist all good
questions made more urgent by the
deplorable State of the Church of
England today a husk of ecclesiology and
Great Britain generally but the more
personal question for all of us is what
precisely is meant by the Guy Fawkes
masks in our cultural and political
battles today who are the real rebels
and who has God on their side good
questions